c'était une chose incroyable je n'ai
jamais vu dans ma vie une chose qu'on
s'a
déjeuner qui s'est lancé sur les
recherches sur les bagues ainsi façon
c'était un spectacle fantastique
je
voilà
je préfère
ap
pour la pointe qu'il a pris
oui ok d'état
vim
c'est un voile déchirée ouais
tout vêtement tragique
perso avec deux semaines
et je pensais
je pense qu'il ya deux manières de voir
le le wave riding ait yalla version un
petit peu snow voire carrément chaud
c'est à dire un twin tip et faire des
courbes qui sont quand même snowboard
donc c'est un peu comme si tu attaques
et les les côtés de piste quoi tu mets
des rollers de dante bdr des trucs comme
ça et c'est vachement des courbes alors
que avec une directionnelle on
n'arrivera plus à surfer des vagues
comme ici peter troubles c'est à dire
tourner sur l'arrière remonté tandis qu
l'air à la lavables et pour aller pour
aller frapper la lèvre ce qui est très
dur avec un twin tip parce qu'on a le
pied qui est loin de l'arrière donc on
contrôle un peu par le milieu et par les
rails donc d'après moi il ya deux à
venir il ya on pourrait d un peu le
snowboard dans les vagues et deux soeurs
dans les vagues assez claire t ces deux
façons de lire les vagues vraiment
différent
ca
c'est
je m'appelle hervé bour et suite rider
chez thakoon et depuis deux ans
voilà
la compétition dans les vagues parce
qu'en fait que ce que je fais depuis
deux ans maintenant
me spécialiser un peu plus dans les
vagues dans les compétitions qu est-il
bien que de temps en temps je fais
encore beaucoup de concessions freestyle
mais c'est vrai que tous les tripes que
je fais à droite et à gauche sont basées
essentiellement sur le wave riding me
suis dit que ça serait peut être sympa
de faire une compétition de l'aïe malgré
que c'est une vague c'est une droite
avec un vent donc tribord moi je suis
vous fit donc
peut-être c'était un peu un challenge
pour moi de venir ici parce que je
savais que bon il y avait des gens qui
est gens qui sont régularisés restant
aguilar que c'est beaucoup plus facile
pour eux d'arriver cette vague je pense
qu'au final je m'en suis pas trop mal
sorti
c'est comme je dis que c'est un
challenge vous attend de voir maintenant
sur une gauche j'espère que l'on fera
bientôt une compétition sur une gauche
les crocs
you think you are falling
m
que ce soit
falling bois
non
pour
je m'appelle mali bouchenafa je suis
algérien je crois rider un société akwan
depuis maintenant bientôt 30 ans
on a toujours un peu peur parce que dans
les montres va comme ça on a toujours
une petite frayeur mais c'est pas
c'est pas la même peur on va dire que
c'est de l'adrénaline c'est un peu une
drogue pour nous donc
c'est
on a encore envie d'écouter des mines de
plus en plus besoin d'aller de prendre
des bases encore plus gros
on a besoin de cette fête notre peur se
transforme en adrénaline et c'est
tellement bon
le parquet ont toujours poussé un peu
plus loin de cette saison à toulon pour
moi le tube 21 500 me fixer depuis
longtemps
surfer les vagues c'est pas mal c'est
bien je pense qu'arriver à saucats les
invités ont reçu un bon coup manqué
recommancer c'est un très très gros
challenge pour moi j'ai vraiment envie
de
d'être l'un des premiers à faire tard
mec
je peux pas
papa
watch
on ne peut pas aller
calculé
à
ce qu'ils sont
d
oh
pas
what
a life du repos avant de repartir à fond
la caisse on va voir thiès soulagé
voilà je vais peut-être christophe que
cinq chez les cailles depuis cinq ans
le calvaire
m
ces longues droites qui déroule sur 2
300 m
avec certaines sections plus abrupte que
d'autres
à part ça pas grand chose on pense à pas
tomber il pense
on pense à attaquer aussi un maximum
et
pour soirée avant tout aussi si
j'attaque un maximum c'est avant tout
pour moi pour faire plaisir et pour me
prouver mes limites moi c'est surtout un
défi par rapport à moi-même je veux me
prouver que je peux sortir les grosses
vagues balaient la vague c'est la
meilleure sensation qu'on puisse avoir
enquêté en france
l'appel catholique port
mikko
le bas
m
ap
labrecque
à
banier
et mac
venez me c'est julian sutra comme faber
france
c'est bon ce témoin mais bon un parfait
aujourd'hui
alors là la lumière
est belle balle
elle
je m'appelle fred compagnon j'ai 27 ans
je fais du cas être depuis trois ans et
en fait avant je faisais
surtout du bodyboard et du chat donc je
suis professionnel de bodyboard
je fais ça depuis l'âge de 12 ans et
quand j'étais gamin je regardais la mer
et quand les vagues étaient trop grosses
je rêvais de pouvoir passer là-bas en
sautant par dessus les vagues et a eu
lieu au pic en ayant sauté par dessus
les vagues à avoir ma planche sous le
bras parce que c'était endroit
vais pas faire des canards arrivé au
fond une demi heure et les jours où j'ai
vu le kite jeudi c'est le rêve que
j'avais quand j'étais gamin c'est sauter
par dessus les bacs pour aller on va les
chercher des vagues des surprises
le webmaster c'est un projet qui
demandera
grossir à grandir je pense bon on
connaît cap vert on est déjà venu
plusieurs années de suite là on a eu des
conditions exceptionnelles les riders se
sont très bien amusés à aider des vagues
exceptionnelles une qualité
exceptionnelle pense que c'est la
meilleure vague le monde le projet en
lui-même c'est la première épreuve c'est
la première épreuve du webmaster donc sa
demande
à continuer à peaufiner
les compétitions de vagues en kite bon
ça c'est que c'est un sport assez jeune
et encore beaucoup de choses à faire
donc il ya eu une première on a déjà
organisé ici des événements sur calvaire
en vagues je pense qu'il ya eu depuis
deux ans il ya une discipline cristal
qui s'est développée en europe et dans
le monde et c'est plutôt un retour aux
sources pour le sport donc il ya une
grosse évolution il ya un potentiel
énorme dans les vagues ça c'est clair ça
c'est évident que il faut avoir foi dans
la vague déjà élevé dans la bonne
direction tout apprête s'approprie pas
vraiment à ce genre d'expérience on doit
pas être très loin il ya d'autres vagues
notamment à tahiti je pense à tahiti et
dans le pacifique où là effectivement
ils vont certainement pouvoir entrer
dans un tube ils dépendent de la
direction du vent et de l'orientation du
ciel mais
c'est un futur c'est évident très bonne
question
j'espère que ça ira le plus loin
possible le mieux possible on voit une
évolution surtout dans les vagues
on a vu ce que
ce qui s'est passé la semaine dernière
où ces deux semaines c'était vendredi
dernier bon bah il a plus il y a plus
photo quoi c'est clair que la discipline
va grandir au niveau des pratiquants
je pense que depuis quatre ans sa part
été progresser c'est en fonction du
matériel aussi du développement de
matériel
l'accessibilité et c'est ça c'est les
marques qui vont faire la différence au
niveau des pratiquants bon ça va
progresser peut-être un peu moins que
les années précédentes mais il y aura
toujours le plus en plus de pratiquants
c'est évident c'est un sport très
spectaculaire et et à mon avis moi j'ai
pratiqué au début donc mais maintenant
vraiment le temps de le faire mais j'ai
eu l'énorme sensation au début je pense
que les coureurs en se retrouvant sur
des vagues comme puta ont des sensations
extrêmement
mittal
et
pas banal
on
rien
et
photo
à
bah
m
à
à eau
sa mort martine mérard kalkan bord du
lac
htc samsung pour mailler
agréable
à
ça me va faire va
travelzoo
il ya du vent je comprend
trois doigts de l'autre
on
va parler pendant une semaine
e
et
camacho
depuis new school
for mac os x
suite
big wave le wing
formule
parfaite
c'est parfait tous les ingrédients sont
réunis maintenant de super conditions de
vent et de vagues et plus de style dans
la rue dans l'arrière pays les animaux
sauvages ont fait au moins 2 r en fait
dans des réserves qui est sympa de rugby
sud réception là près du cap vert où
c'était plutôt désertique
c
on
à
coc
pour
le vôtre